Ancient Graffiti were much different
than modern graffiti modern graffiti are
typically illegal or at least Taboo in
cities today Ancient Graffiti were
welcome or even permitted they appear in
nearly every space in the ancient city
temples tombs bars and even inside homes
so they took to the walls to send
messages to one another this was a
graffito a message written by a proud
papa on the walls of ancient Pompeii
nearly 2 000 years ago line graffiti
allow us to hear the thoughts and words
of ordinary people who lived in
Antiquity but I believe by studying
Roman graffiti we can learn a lot more
about what makes us human and a lot more
about ourselves too